I've now played over 100 hours of
Starfield across multiple playthroughs
and here are my big tips to set you up
for the best possible playthrough number
one I'm sure a lot of you already know
this but do the Mantis Quest early most
things are not worth picking up
including food you get over incumbent in
this game very fast but I regret
spending so many points on weightlifting
you might think you want to pick up a
bunch of stuff in order to sell it but
the truth is you get so many credits so
fast just for doing basic quests in this
game coming directly off my
weightlifting regrets be careful about
what you choose to level up don't spend
a skill point just because you have one
hold the points while you complete the
challenges and then level up the things
you really care about it's especially
important because as far as I'm aware
someone correct me if I'm wrong there's
absolutely no way to respect in this
game as an extra aside there I wish that
I unlocked piloting a lot earlier
another one that's really helped me as
I've continued is to buy every medpack
and every Digi pick from every vendor
always I can make this video way longer
but the last one I'm going to leave it
on because I definitely didn't know
until way too late if you sleep in your
ship's bed you will get an XP boost
don't just leave the ship immediately